today on good morning mug club we have
an interview with doug to naples he's a
comic book artist he created some of the
greatest video games from your childhood
and mine
and yeah steven did an entire interview
with him during this
interview doug plugged his kickstarter
for earthworm gem 2 the graphic novel
so the problem is that kickstarter has
ended i know sad story but
today for you doug has opened and
any indiegogo campaign so that you can
still back the book
and get your copy so uh if you enjoy the
interview if you're familiar with doug's
work or if you just like to support one
of the best artists and storytellers
going right now
go to indiegogo search for earthworm gem
2 and back the book i hope you enjoy
this interview
and i'll get off the screen thank you so
[Music]
much
all right very glad to have my next
guest i wasn't i wasn't super familiar
like months ago with the name right
until it was audio weighed and quarter
black garrett said
no earthworm gym i said there's one gym
that's my gym yeah i think that was
my first game that i ever beat
that's a hard game too yeah it's even
harder on sega compared to super
nintendo sega is the
the way to go no genesis i get it you
thought you were cool with mortal kombat
avoiding
you know your parents so they didn't see
the fatalities but the truth is the
gameplay was uh better
it was for homos now uh talking about
that the next speaking of earthworms
our next guest uh as doug he created
earthworm jim he's created all sorts of
video games comic books uh cartoons he's
voiced them as well which i want to ask
him about
he is uh right now running there's a
kickstarter campaign for earthworm gym
2.
fight the fish is a sequel to the comic
book
caught a lot of flack lately people talk
about uh attempts to cancel and i always
say why don't people stand up to them
more well this next uh
man does he has the ground to stand on
mr doug to naples how are you sir
i'm so good steven thanks for having me
on i appreciate you so much
huge fan don't say i'm a monster fan of
you i watch you guys all the time and of
course i'm a friend of quarter black
garrett hey bill
are you guys you guys been talking yeah
yeah i worked i actually did uh the
design for his trading cards on the
first earthworm gym
campaign really i didn't yeah did you he
designed a 90 card
set wow well that's a lot of claims why
he wasn't working on the show
did him off time what are you just going
to keep him a day raider or do you want
him full time because he's going to be
on the open market soon
he is amazing i will say about
quarterback garrett he came in uh we did
the golden ticket sweepstakes and i've
talked about this
where he came in and he wasn't quite
there for for editing because he didn't
have the experience you know at that
point but we just loved his attitude
and so we brought him back for whatever
we could do and then he would build
these
full freaking costumes and animatronic
things and
we'd go get it what you can do this he's
like well yeah he said all right okay
you're hired
i just did it on the side and then the
next day it's like a fully accurate r2d2
replica
made from pots and a recycling bin we
hired you to be creative we didn't know
you were a creative creator yes
my bad but we didn't know he was like
arts and crafts creative we didn't know
you're hiring a partner from michael's
i'm such a super fan that is another
tribute is that on the last bigfoot bill
campaign i did
a uh half asian bill uh sticker
that's right uh bigfoot bill oh wow
that's right
we need to we could if maybe we can get
some of these things and sell them on
the site uh or you know
obviously you can sell them through our
site we uh we're always surprised at the
buying power of our site because we sold
like
hundreds of thousands of dollars uh of
the david dorn shirts yeah yeah yeah
um still going which by the way andorn
wanted us to know that it's going to a
scholarship in in david doran's name oh
so cool
so that was already really cool on ours
but yeah um all right well doug sorry we
got off on on
not the wrong foot but who is it so
explain people who don't
know you kind of what what your
background is
obviously everyone sort of knows
earthworm gym but your involvement and
then we can get to you know why so many
people want to hurt you
sure sure um i've so earthworm gym is my
biggest hit
obviously from the early to mid 90s but
i also did the neverhood and skull
monkeys is another video game i did for
dreamworks
i've worked for every major studio doing
games and then i started doing comic
books
i did the book gear
creature tech these are all books i
ended up selling into hollywood for
millions of dollars i started selling
the ips in and they didn't know i was a
christian
this is i've always been vocal but just
just there wasn't an internet to get the
word out
right um and then that also opened up
doors into television so i was an exec
producer on the earthworm gym animated
series
and then i did a a a show version of
gear the comic book for nickelodeon
called cat scratch
this is before it went full blue hair
lgbt over
there oh i thought it was maybe a little
bit of a send up to you know a little
wink and a nod to ted
nugent who also would yeah it's a great
song
yeah and then uh and then so i've just
always done video games tv
and so when people say that like uh
conservative christians aren't that
creative my
that raises my hackles a little bit
because i've i've always
operated on the front lines of the world
that's my
that's where i want to be i want to
leave the 99 to go after the one i'm
trying to find people
who maybe have never heard the gospel or
never seen
a christian creative out in the depths
of hollywood and video gaming and comic
books and i've done 20 graphic novels
those are long form comic books right
and this earthworm gym 2 is my 20th so i
i got the rights back just for the book
and started doing crowd funding
to kind of protect my career and do it
independently
yeah well i think what's interesting is
you just mentioned this you came at it
honestly in that you made it in an
industry at that point people didn't
really know that you were a christian as
opposed to
i don't want to say grifting but there
are a lot of people who effectively like
as a stand-up comedian i performed at a
church once and it was because my friend
was a youth pastor it was like some kind
of a graduation
and then he told me we had and i won't
name names so and so in here and these
were people i'd never heard of he said
they clean up
making millions of dollars doing the
church circuit but they've never been
comedians before they go no they just
were pastoring a church and they started
being comedians there's a big difference
between
making it work because you sort of use i
want to say gimmick but you know that
you're performing just for that niche
and
happening to be a christian where your
values define you but making it in the
deepest talent pool
which not only did you do but earthworm
gym and not that that's the only thing
you've done but for me growing up like
that is a marker in my childhood that
was one of the most
uh iconic games out you had mario and
you had
uh sonic and then earthworm jim came in
and surprisingly as a christian guy was
considered like edgier
for me as a kid earthworm gym yeah the
first thing i saw of yours was your
imitation you did
of um tom cruise
so before i knew you were a christian i
knew you were funny and you were
talented
and to me that's a high compliment when
someone likes your work
because of your your clip you don't even
know what talent is
if you had done the research as i had
done the research
do the fake laugh you got to do this
i don't know if he could actually i'm
sure he would have like a he would have
a 7 by 70 cigar just because he's more
comfortable with it
um by the way we're smoking a pipe in
cigar because uh we found out that we
both uh
sure we are brothers of the leaf and the
briar not the leaf that you have in your
belt buckle
different one um yes but sorry but
continue yeah it was it was considered
edgier though too
um earthworms you remember as a kid like
there were some things it wasn't mortal
kombat but i remember as a kid
you know with christian parents being
like oh i don't know if i want them to
see this level there's boogers
yeah we were very into uh warner
brothers cartoons
and tex avery you know the the classic
warner brothers stuff
and the music we listened to we were
into weird al and they might be giants
and cake this is all
kind of 90s stuff yeah and we just
wanted
you know video games were not very
creative at the time and so he wanted to
bring in
something a little more um
like non-sequitur freaky funny
um and and the tech side of
this is the tech side of earthworm gym
that really doesn't get enough credit
it was so hard to cram that much art
into a cartridge because you're talking
about an amount of memory of like a
postage stamp
like a floppy disk so the tech guys were
able to
to compress the art so well that it gave
us way more
frames of animation that allowed us to
put in more gags and more humor
right limited memory yeah and then they
had like an n64 they had the expansion
pack
kids don't appreciate this now their
phone has more technology than we had in
all of our systems and computers for
crying out loud first time
first time i found out what an emulator
was when computers had gotten good
enough i said wait
i can have all my super nintendo games
in a folder
on a disk so so you've worked in the
industry for obviously a very long time
um and i want to get to kind of our
connection with andrew breitbart and in
big hollywood
but first for people so what is it that
has uh pissed people off about you i
know you've had the lgbtq aaip
yeah silent f after you recently a quick
search
why i mean you frost your tips you'd
think you'd be friendly
yeah they've been they've been after me
for since the beginning
is um i i oppose gay marriage i've i've
said that
gay marriage is between a man one man
and one woman well that would be
that would not be gay marriage between
one man and woman a gay marriage between
a man and one woman would be weird that
was yeah
with the gender spectrum now who knows
that could be an accurate statement
and so i've only that's really the the
basics of my
disagreement with them is just is over
the marriage issue it wasn't
and that i don't endorse so i won't
endorse and i've
obviously in animation and even on my
graphic novels i've had
gay crew members and trans crew members
and there was never a problem with them
it's with specific council culture
groups that are online
organized behind the scenes there's
probably 30 of them in some
discord or forum somewhere where they
all launch their attacks
against all of my vendors and try to get
me canceled so
on kickstarter they'll send you know 30
emails a day
to kickstarter to try and get them to
remove my campaign
anytime one of my scholastic books would
come out you know scholastic
this is hostile territory like
scholastic they have a rainbow
their name is in rainbow when they
launch their books right
i just thought that was innocent because
i was a kid looking through it
effectively it looked like a couponer
flyer and i was like oh look a new
berenstain bears yeah
i have to well i'll get that in a mere
nine and a half weeks
and and they're all full black lives
matter now you know they all give their
donations to black lives matter
kickstarter all of my vendors image
comics indiegogo
you know we're all on youtube also and
so
it to me it's really just anti
specifically conservative christians
because they'll give a christian a pass
if you're okay with gay marriage and if
you're okay
with you know abortion or whatever then
you're the good kind of christian like
basically they're okay with christians
like uh like rob bell you know who are
going to hell
yeah yeah rob i didn't believe in it
yeah i guess i'm here because love wins
love wins and i'm on fire oh it really
is a pit
wait a second i thought this was
figurative little on the nose
god yeah no yeah
we're seeing the last five years really
is uh a ramping up
of and the mainstreaming of political
correctness because this is all stuff i
heard of in the 90s and i just thought
it was like some little campus joke they
were like doug
political correctness is coming and
they're going to get you and i'm like no
they're not they're a bunch of freaks on
a campus somewhere
right and now you've seen them come into
full fruition in mainstreaming politics
even dragging both parties over to the
left
and you see it in the church you see it
all over the church now
yeah and in major businesses that are
doing the
the rainbow logo and the black lives
matter
logo on you know taking over their
corporations and now you're seeing the
mainstreaming of it and
i don't know exactly what's going to
happen in the future but
i put my career in i'm here to do my
best
and then i just put the rest of my
career in god's hands i'm here to fight
and as soon as he wants me canceled i'll
get canceled but until then
i'm going to be as vocal as i can be and
well and it's sad that
you know i've been really disappointed
in the church with black lives matter
with kovid they you know
when gyms and other businesses are
opening up and churches refuse to
congregate
i go all right you don't deserve my
tithe anymore i'm going to find a church
with balls and especially when you
consider
i'm not mistaken wasn't it your latest
kickstarter though uh
the didn't it go from like zero to
entirely funded in 13 minutes so there's
a market out there yeah but christians
are afraid to speak up and i'm more
disappointed with them
than i am with people who don't know
better i i agree and this goes back to
the mug club too is we need to hear the
support of our people
need to come out and back us so that
vocally even because it's it
and you need to write in and say i'm
i'm backing because of this and good job
guys i'm thinking of you i'm rooting for
you even if you're not a christian i'm
saying we need to hear from you guys
yeah it because it usually it amazes me
how many guys on our side are just quiet
and they
it's too easy to go along to get along
and it's time to fight if you don't
speak up
you're going to lose yeah my advice is
you're going to lose everything
your freedoms anyways you know the
church is always going to be fine
but i don't feel public about it you're
going to lose the ability to speak of it
in public
yeah i don't know if the church will
always be fine because i tell you what i
think the worry was
for a long time for the church they
would say we don't want to speak out
politically and lose our 501 c 3 status
and
in california you know audio weight has
made this great point that
really that speaking out is just meeting
right that's illegal in california at
least it was for a long time
that's the new punk rock you know rage
against the machine
actually morello is endorsing the
machine that prevents pastors and church
ladies from meeting so i don't know what
point he
stopped
doug wilson up in moscow idaho they're
going like we're not wearing masks i'm
going like yes
someone's alive someone's here still
breathing
here in tennessee is full-on compliant
like
social distancing my daughter goes to
lipscomb university this is like the
church of christ
conservative campus like duck dynasty
you know church of christ
and they're like all the students are
all like lgbt
black lives matter she's all dad you'd
be in shock at this is in
tennessee yeah they went for trump in
the primary you know
well you know what's interesting is you
mentioned that like i think i think
we're both
we can both be very clear i have no
problem with lgbt people being in the
church i have no problem with people who
disagree but
the problem now is this isn't just
someone who has a certain attraction or
someone who
feels that they're a different gender
than they're biological we won't even
get into that the difference is now
this group is a political uh wing that
is trying to actively remove anyone who
doesn't accept
their sometimes anti-scientific
narratives wholesales like hey you're
welcome in the church
doesn't mean just like people are
welcome in the church if they're
shacking up and living together but
we're not going to say that that's god's
plan we believe you should get married
hey you can prefer a different kind of
friction
we don't care how hairy uh what you rub
up against really is
but it doesn't mean that the bible the
word changes but you're welcome here and
hopefully we'll try and work on this
together but the difference is now those
people are saying you shouldn't exist
in the industry as you work in the
entertainment industry and now they also
want to of course we see this
destroy the churches themselves by
removing their taxes can't feed your
family unless you agree and
i'll make that other statement on lgbt
too any gay person that i know i'm a way
worse sinner than you
saved by grace i'm way worse than you
i'm not saying i'm better than any lgbt
person
there is a difference just like black
lives matter it's we're all against
racism but black lives matter
is a neo-marxist movement and so is the
lgbt movement
the same thing with environmentalism
they've been taken over
by formal marxists who are
pushing this ideology so i it's that's
what i'm fighting that's what i'm at war
with not an individual
person who is struggling with sin or has
a problem with it i mean
i i just i just really feel like i'm one
of the worst people i know because i
know myself so well
right yeah i think that's every person
all of you the only person who didn't
feel that way was jesus imagine that his
internal diagnosis was like
i'm awesome no wait don't say that good
because then you you need to humble
yourself i'm all right so he's all my
truth
is actually the truth yeah yeah what
does my truth mean
i know everything um no that's that's a
very good point and you know people also
need to understand that marxism
uh the people actually read karl marx
it's a distinctly
anti-god theology it's a distinctly
atheistic hopeless philosophy and a big
part of it is replacing the idea that
the cultural the central figurehead of
god and replacing the god-shaped hole
that people have in their lives
with government and this idea of forced
community people don't
you may not be that version of a
socialist communist or mark but that is
its origin there's no denying that i
think a lot of these people don't know
it and that's why they see it as black
versus white rather than
actually uh virtue freedom versus
enforced atheism and nihilism long term
yeah that's something that we learned
from breitbart
back in the day sitting at his knee is
he
he saw all of this coming because he
knew he read so much of he read
so much of marx he actually went to the
source yeah and
and understood where this is going it is
a materialist philosophy so it
it tends to be rooted in materialism
this is something that prager always
said is the thing that marx always says
is like
everything is about money that's all
that he ever understood was like that
money and power right and there's no
supernatural or immaterial truth
and you and you start to see their
marching orders that they go
under it starts to involve them going to
power centers and going to areas that
control money
right now that's very interesting is
they're obsessed
with money for this idea of the
bourgeois this idea of this upper class
who have all the money
and it shouldn't be that important
everything is about redistribution it's
about how people who have more time for
leisure if they're paid enough will be
more
happy be more productive it's about how
this money should be spread what social
safety net and with
jesus is give unto caesar what is caesar
and god what is god's
all right the same man doesn't have a
place to lay his head right yeah exactly
and they could cancel you and i today
and take
all of our money they can't take your
wife they can't take your kids they
can't take your
your your uh your freedom you know what
i mean they can't take so many
immaterial things
but all they know is just i'm going to
get crowder by take i'm going to
de-platform him on youtube
and then he'll be as miserable as me
well now they are trying to take
now they are trying to take your kids
they want that's why they're going after
the public school system and they want
to disallow you see this group at
harvard right because of covid a lot of
people realizing hey my kids learning
more effectively with homeschooling and
i actually like spending time with my
kids rather than dropping off at daycare
so you had these committees come forward
and people from the ivy league saying no
no
no we need to make sure that now we have
control over homeschooling
where they learn that uh biological sex
is a figment of their imagination
you know and so on and so forth i
believe that's in the curriculum
somewhere near the back
yeah so it really is uh remember people
saying this is slippery slope oh this is
just a dot they're not coming for your
kids
now they're coming free kids yeah they
they know that you're not worthy to
raise your own kids they're the smart
people to come and
but just brainwash them my kids are uh
they got a classic education so i
i kind of bullet we we we call it
ruining our kids
they've been ruined yeah ruining them
with the great american classics like
twain
i never read any of that i never as a
kid i never read any of that and i was
raised in canada granted the only
classic we read was lord of the flies
um and everything else was i remember
looking back was a book called tears of
a tiger my
junior year and it was a total social
justice thing and i didn't even know i
was reading like ah really man the cops
are really beating on this black guy
that was my review that's like i you
know at this point it might have been
the 10th grade i do not like it when
police officers beat up black men
because they are racist give me an a
please
you read lord of the flies and then you
saw it paraded before you in reality and
chop
right i know that's exactly what
happened we that's the we were just
concerned that we had
quarterback garrett wears contacts
because we didn't want people to start a
fire and take his glasses
broke my heart as a kid what they did
with piggy and then i remember i messed
up
and you know what that's actually a
perfect analogy you know a lot of your
your uh
your games and a lot of your your
graphic novels sorry i almost said comic
books i'm not
that [ __ ] you're no you're allowed hey
i'm a cartoonist
okay all right i'm like one old
hoity-toity graphic novel you get some
people have a
thing about that uh but you know you
inject humor into it quite a bit i
remember reading lord of the flies
and it really bothered me once they
killed
spoiler alert piggy and then when
we had to read it out loud in class
i got that portion i read it and i
started laughing uncontrollably and i
i hate to use this sort of self
self-psycho analysis but
it was definitely because i was
uncomfortable with something that it
really bothered me as a kid it was
traumatic
and so i decided to deal with it with
laughter and then making jokes about it
which is kind of an important thing
people understand
making a joke about something or la
doesn't mean you're making light of it
sometimes it's just a processing
mechanism
yeah and you know you're a comedian uh
you don't care who laughs at your joke
any laugh is good enough
right so we're we're publicly trying to
i think alleviate the suffering of our
audience like you bring some joy and
some happiness and i want earth from jim
to be enjoyed by everyone
including ideological opponents i'm not
trying to
i never say like uh if you're on the
left don't buy my work it's
i i want to seduce you i want to make
i'm going to make you laugh i'm going to
give you a good time i'm going to give
you a good value for what you
pay me for and i want to put on a great
show that's uh
that's our ministry that sound bites
going to be taken i want to seduce you
in the lgbt you're going baby steps
we got him we got him yeah
i will sit in the bathhouse with you and
read you my books
oh my gosh you don't know how strong of
a gay conservative contingency have
right now they're all biting their
knuckles like that time brad pitt came
over the hill and the legends of the
fall are going
um no no one else i still have marks in
my hand